welcome back millennials and
more specifically gen ziers because we
are so excited to be joined by a true
icon and someone we talk about here a
lot on the morning toast
the one the only emma chamberlain hi
emma
hi thank you guys for having me we're so
excited the pleasure is
all ours it's such a pleasure and the
pleasure really belongs to
our little sister so we don't want to
ambush you
um but our little sister would literally
like slit our throats in our sleep if
she didn't like join and say hi she is
literally your number one fan
i literally was like really made it
sound like
she was 11. so i was like this is her
nanny oh my god
oh my god her name is margo we call her
snitch and we call her snitch
chamberlain she loves you
and she just looks up to you and she
would like be so mad at us if we didn't
let her get in the
zoom well i would be mad too it's so
nice to meet you
three that's what this is the best day
of my life like this is the best day of
her life
you crying when you got your hair cut in
your youtube video like i have laughed
about that
for every day centuries i've seen it
since i've seen it
same shame
me too i'm so glad that i finally found
a hair color that didn't make me look
like
um a harry potter character so i'm
feeling about that
you look great i feel like i've been
following you a lot in quarantine and i
think you're one of the people who's
actually thriving in quarantine
honestly i kind of agree in the
beginning i was like this is awful
i don't know what to do whatever but now
this is like the best thing that's ever
happened to me and i love
not hanging out with anybody and i love
the self-discovery and
like i'm learning how to do my makeup i
mean it's been good
like i don't know you look good thank
you
and i get to like go outside you know a
little bit here and there
like sit in the sun i guess i mean it
hasn't been the worst for me
i feel like i'm making it through in a
good way
it's good have you learned any new
skills
well i have been trying to like i mean
i've had so much time
right so let's say when i need to get
ready for something like
say i need to get ready for this i'll
like take an extra hour to try and make
my makeup look really good
and that's something that i've never had
the time for before so that's kind of
fun
um besides that i got really good at
fortnight and that's super embarrassing
and i don't want to talk about that
um and then i quit recently because i
was like you know what emma we need to
move on from this this is not
this is not admirable so then i stopped
but that's about it
i also learned how to do puzzles uh
quickly
i'm such a puzzle girly girl and there's
truly nothing more
accomplishing than finishing a puzzle oh
i know it's like
serious endorphins i mean you have dogs
you have cats right
i do i have cats you have to make sure
they don't pick up a piece in their
mouth because don't ask me how many
times i've finished a puzzle without the
last piece
oh that almost happened with one and i'm
not kidding i
luckily they just knocked it off the
table but i'm serious i
i i almost was like mom
can you just take the cats like i can't
i'm so sorry but this is they're ruining
things that are very important to me
um it's terrible they're still here on
my bed now but you know
cute okay so you are here you're
launching a new project the ideal
planner
which is a planner but it's it's beyond
the stereotypical like
you're going to do great today planner
which can be a little
um honestly sometimes condescending and
i love that you're taking a different
approach to it
so tell us a little bit about this
project how it came to be why i love
a planner love like so hard same
same well i mean obviously the same
because i made one but
but i agree like i've always just gotten
so like
cringed out by the planners that you buy
you know what i'm saying like they're
always
so corny and again condescending like
the way that they're
telling you how to like you know
set goals and do all this stuff it's
like it just doesn't feel
inviting to me it almost makes me feel
like i'm
a piece of [ __ ] so totally like yeah and
i don't know why they're all like that
but
i was like you know what i want to take
a different approach i want a more
you know comforting and
relatable form of a planner so that more
people are inspired
to plan and be organized and stuff like
that because it's so
important and i feel like it's been one
of the
staples of my organization routine
since i was literally in fifth grade and
i just wanted to share that
joy with everybody but i feel like a lot
of people are kind of put off by the
by the vibe of normal planners so i
wanted to create the
complete opposite and also put like some
fun stuff in it so that
it's kind of also like something that
you could bring on a plane and like
doodle in
or if you have anxiety and you want to
go sit in your backyard and like doodle
in it or do whatever like
those are options too so i felt like it
was the perfect
ideal planner that was kind of my
approach i see what you did there
well it says it has journal pages custom
mood boards
puzzles games lists corny quotes cool
designs and silly messages
from you i think that's a great idea i
love that you thought of it with like
planes in mind
because there's just never anything to
do on a plane and now i've got a puzzle
i've got a journal i've got games i
think that's fabulous
exactly thank you and also sometimes we
need to get off our phone and stop
playing candy crush on the plane that's
my personal opinion
continue totally also you add the days
that you want to plan
for so because like sometimes there's
days on my planner that are just
completely empty and it really gives me
shame shame shame same
absolutely same and so that's why i was
like i want to
make it so that you can pick this back
up like you put it down for a month
and then you can pick it back up and you
can like start up like you can whatever
it's so
flexible um and i felt that for people
who are
new to maybe using a planner or
you know are just they're not in school
so they're like kind of have on and off
days whatever
um or they are in school sorry so they
have like summer where they don't need
to plan and then right
well you know what i'm saying so it's
like being efficient with the space it's
not like any page
needs to be wasted and i thought yeah i
actually sometimes i was
i know what you're gonna say and i do
the same thing i actually sometimes like
backlog
my planner so that when i look back on
it
i feel more accomplished i also like add
things that are so fake and like not
real
just so that i don't look like a piece
of [ __ ] who has like one meeting a day
i'm like
take dog for a walk when i like was
inside the whole day
same same and like i'll literally put
the dumbest like i
will be like take a shower it's like
obviously
taking a shower god bless but like no
i'm i'm
totally there i i do the same that's so
funny well you talked
and i like that you had it in mind when
it's like whether you're having anxiety
and you just like sometimes need your
mind to take
you need to take your mind off things um
i think part of one of the reasons so
many people
like love you in your youtube channel
and i know i can speak for our sister
our seven-year-old sister who um like
loves you
i think what what she really connects
with you on is you're so open about
mental health and a lot of people
your age and even anyone's age is are
not open about it
and i want to ask you why you made that
conscious decision to talk about it on
your youtube channel
um be so open about it and has that
helped you in your journey
totally i have always
well actually i wasn't always super open
about it like in my real life
um to kind of like hold it in whatever
but
to me talking about it in front of a
camera was almost like talking about it
to myself which i do literally every day
anyway
and when nobody was really watching you
know what i'm saying and it was like my
channel was
a lot smaller and there's only a handful
of people that were tuning in
um to me it just felt like i was talking
to myself and i was like
okay it's easy for me to open up because
i don't feel like a lot of people are
watching
but also so it's not like there's all
this pressure
but also i feel like if somebody were to
stumble upon this video i feel like it
would be useful you know what i mean
right
and so that was super important to me
was like okay
you know it's not easy to talk about
these things
but also if i'm doing it by myself it's
easy and somebody's gonna get something
out of it
so i'm gonna push away that discomfort
and i'm just gonna do it and then it
became kind of like muscle memory for me
where
i just started to be super open in front
of the camera and it was not scary to me
because
i wasn't talking to somebody directly
there was no response so i was like this
is easy
and then i started to see how actually
people really were connecting
to it and it was helping them and then
now it's just like that's just how my
brain works and i do that
in my personal life too now i'm
constantly having these open
conversations
about you know mental health and how our
brains are working
you know uh with my friends and family
more than i probably would have
otherwise but seeing how like
you know much it resonates with people
through the internet showed me that like
we're all kind of the same you know what
i mean
yeah we're all we all are struggling
with the same things when you look at
somebody and you're like oh my god
you know they have it all figured out
they don't and i think that
um you know once you realize that
it's a lot easier to just kind of go for
it and just you know
have that conversation with everybody
and make it fun too like it doesn't
always need to be
super dark and depressing you know yeah
and like so serious and i think
lightening it up is why like a lot of
young people really respond
to the content you put out totally
um you're just doing like the most at
all times and i find it so interesting
just as like someone who
is involved in social media just to see
the different lanes like
one can take and i find like every time
you launch a project you work on
something it's so deeply personal
and it's so different like i don't know
anyone who's made a planner i don't know
anyone who launched your own coffee
company
and it's all very on brand for you and i
find it just so interesting to watch you
um chamberlain coffee which is your
coffee company which is fabulous i've
heard rave reviews i don't personally
drink coffee but if i did i would be a
chamberlain coffee girl
can you talk to me a little bit about
how you decide you know what projects to
take on
yes well i definitely
can't work on something for more than
five minutes unless i'm obsessed with it
i get
really really bored and mad um my team
knows this about me and
uh it's probably annoying but i
genuinely
like i have to work on things that
excite me and so
i tend to lean toward more towards like
a passion project over something that's
like
kind of like a super big money maker
like i'd rather
you know take my time and work on
something that's super
interesting to me and something that is
exciting to me
than something that like i know will
like me it's more like
these things are passion projects for me
even if that makes sense
and i think that that's why they tend to
be more personal
is because i'm not as concerned about
you know
how much money i'm gonna make from it or
you know stuff like that
with these like more specific endeavors
so like you know the planner being a
good one
coffee being a huge one that's like the
biggest one i have going on right now
it's like i
i want to almost do it for me like i i
it's a dream of mine to you know do
anything in coffee that's always been a
dream of mine
um so that's why once i had the
opportunity i was like i don't really
care about anything else except for
making this exactly what i've dreamed of
and that
right you know other elements of it
whatever
i just want to make this something that
i'm obsessed with and that you know i'm
excited about that i would buy and that
you know
i love and then i can hope that
everybody agrees and you know if not
we'll figure it out but i just do these
things for me
i think um and i mean i also don't
let anybody sway me any different way
like be like well you should probably go
this direction because this is doing
really well right now or this or that
i'm like no i don't care like that's not
why i work on these things like i work
on these things because
they're like something i'm passionate
about you know what it means yeah and
it's like
create the coffee that you wish to see
in the world or the planner that you
want to use right
and then it naturally becomes an
extension of yourself totally that's
exactly it yeah she created the podcast
she wanted to see in the world too a
fellow
podcaster we have so much respect for
fellow podcasters we must support
other podcasters podcasters supporting
podcasters and i feel like you're
you're actually like the perfect person
for a podcast i feel like you just have
an interesting take on literally
everything like even the most
small minutiae um and i think that's
what makes your podcast so funny and
interesting and you it's called anything
goes for those who want to listen
um tell us about that tell us about the
podcasting process i feel like you have
a lot to say
okay i don't know about you guys like i
know it's probably so different for
everybody i have the most
weird strategy like almost the most
kitschy one too like i
literally have my little handheld
microphone thing
i take it to my closet because it like
you know the noise
the echo yeah um and then i lay on the
ground
uh in my closet with the microphone
plugged in
and i record my episode for probably
like an hour and then every thursday i
record on thursdays which is also when i
post the podcast
and then um i don't think about it again
for the rest of the week and try to
think about everything but it so that i
can
come up with new things to talk about by
the next week
um and then
that's that i mean i i used to do so i
had two podcasts i had one that was
called stupid genius that now i like
realized was just not the right
direction to go it was like kind of a
science-based podcast
and um i love science and that was like
fun but it just didn't work because
didn't have the legs that it needed to
have and i ended up loving the podcast
format so much that i was like
i want to make something that literally
i can talk about whatever i want
and like right do whatever i want almost
like how my youtube channel is because
my youtube channel
has no structure it's just whatever i
want to be that week and i was like why
am i not doing that with my podcast
so i basically just turned it into that
where i just do whatever
feels right that day and talk about
whatever feels right that day it could
be stories advice
i might eventually have guests on i
don't know i kind of hate that idea but
also we'll see
um i kind of like it to be my therapy
time but whatever
um but yeah and i mean i love it like i
really love it and this new format
with anything goes so much better for me
and i just love to
shoot the [ __ ] for an hour and then see
what it edits into
and then yeah it's it's great and i feel
like it's a more intimate
thing for me with with the people yes
you know
it's very easy to get personal like in
your closet when you're wearing no
makeup laying on the floor and i think
that's why podcasting is such a fabulous
format and why it's so popular
is because you say things you would
never say to your friends you would
might not say on your youtube channel
there's just like a real level of
calm and like there's a therapeutic
nature to it
yeah and the amount of talking that you
have to do like just allows you to get
to the heart of the matter
you know you can take your time with
things totally
yeah okay so the ideal planner is out
now you can buy it on amazon barnes and
noble anywhere you buy books
make sure to get it if you're tired of
being judged by your planner which i
know i
definitely am because today's just not
the day i'm gonna achieve my goals it's
not
and that's okay emma it's okay amen
amen thank you emma for being here i
mean i'm sure you guys already do but
follow emma on instagram
youtube and check out her podcast
anything oh wait thank you for reminding
me because i wanted to talk to you about
tick tock
oh great i'm like the oldest person on
tick tock um
and i'm also like the worst at it i have
only 85 000 followers and like it kills
me
and you like have really successfully
converted your
following onto tick tock honestly one of
the most successful i've seen like major
kudos i'm like
so jealous and happy for you yeah can
you talk about that was that like an
intentional thing did you just like fall
into tick-tock and you loved it and you
wanted to be creative
or did you strategically be like i'm
gonna be the next biggest tick tocker in
the world
literally no like for me tick tock was
something where i
re-downloaded it because it used to be
musically i re-downloaded it
um i was like i have no idea what to do
here i just started watching them and
then i got obsessed with watching them
and then eventually i was like okay i
guess i'll make them
and in the beginning it was just so
traumatizingly traumatizing
to like i can't look back at my old tech
talk that literally
hurts my body um but then i just kind of
like
started having fun with it and to be
honest there was no thought process
behind it i literally
just went on the app i was like this is
what's popping right now i'll check it
out whatever it's kind of part of my job
to kind of know what's going on so
that's what's going on there i ended up
really liking it and then
now i just use it honestly as like
kind of like a fun little you know it's
there's it's not a lot of pressure
you know what i mean it's not like with
an instagram photo where i'm like
this outfit better be crazy um you know
whatever or like with my youtuber it's
like this editing
better be the best like it's not i don't
have those thoughts
with tick tock it's so mindless and
that's why i love it
um but it's also fun because i feel like
the community on tick tock is so like
intimate and everybody
like everybody's in on the same inside
jokes and that's why i kind of love it
even though i also kind of made it
kind of an evil platform but whatever um
but yeah i mean i don't know i'm happy
to be on it and i
literally can't wait to watch your tick
tocks after we're done with this thing
oh my god emma if you follow me
i'll literally die also can you agree
that there's there's something really
humbling about like watching yourself
dance on tick tock
oh my god when i look back at my when i
look back at my old videos
of me dancing my friend and i used to
dance and we would like i was a
cheerleader for like six years i like
love dancing i can remember a routine
very quickly which is a great skill for
tick tock
god bless it is it's so hard i know and
so that i can't imagine like it's even
hard and i had to learn routines all the
time
being a cheerleader and i can't imagine
having no dance background or anything
and trying to remember those i would not
be able to do it
hi so hard it's so hard
and then you spend so much time trying
to remember and you're like there's my
whole day you know and it's like not
only when you're putting together the
perfect tick tock
you have to remember the steps which is
easily the hardest part you have to look
like you're not
trying to remember the steps you have to
be like that's so right
that is so it it's so true because i
will literally like get a dance down
and um or like whatever and i will watch
it back and i'll be like emma why is
your face like
you know you're thinking your eyebrows
are across you're like one or two
side step right left your mouse is like
pursed like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes totally
well okay emma's gonna go check out my
tic tac i have to go record better
content so i gotta go
um thank you so much for being here
again check out all of emma's projects
the ideal planners out now on amazon
barnes and noble and anywhere you can
buy books thank you emma for being here
we hope you had fun
and we will see you guys next week have
a fabulous day
thank you guys so much peace and love